all right hello and welcome to the
reason live stream I'm Zach Weissmuller
and today we're gonna be talking about a
very interesting legal case working its
way up through the federal courts that
cuts to one of the most important Free
Speech issues of our time
when does government communication with
social media companies cross the line
from voluntary partnership into illegal
censorship is there even such a line
the case is known as Missouri V Biden
though as we'll see soon there are many
more plaintiffs and defendants involved
and joining me today to dig into the
details is one of the plaintiffs someone
likely familiar to our audience Dr J
bhattacharya professor of medicine
economics and health research policy at
Stanford University and pertinent to
this conversation one of the signatories
to the Great Barrington declaration
which prompted NIH director Francis
Collins to call for a Swift and
devastating takedown to of its calls to
end lockdowns in favor of focus
protection Jay thank you for joining us
thank you for having me Zach
also here is John uh vecchione senior
litigation council with the new civil
liberties Alliance a non-profit Law Firm
representing Jay and several other
parties to the lawsuit he knows this
material inside it out and will really
be able to explain the legal intricacies
at play here John thank you for talking
with us today it's good to be here
for our audience we are live today and
hope to get to some of your questions so
leave those in the chat and we'll get to
them soon but first for you John a
little background on ncla I'm somewhat
familiar because you handled another
case I reported on challenging a medical
misinformation law in California
but what is the new civil liberties
Alliance and how and why did you all get
involved in this case which was
originally brought by the State
Attorneys General in Missouri and
Louisiana right that was probably the
Hobe case but what I what I'm uh for us
the new civil liberties was founded
about five years ago by Phil Hamburg
he's a professor at Columbia University
who has done uh seminal work on the
administrative state which is the
administrative agency's uncontrolled by
Congress or even the executive in some
cases and so we Sue administrative
agencies primarily but not always for
going beyond the step their statutory
remit or violating the Constitution and
that's our mission and that's what we do
and that's what we're doing here
um how we got involved in this is we
actually had uh a case before Missouri V
Biden uh called Chan Gizzy that's on
appeal in the sixth circuit and I
originally brought by my my my Once and
Future colleague Janine Nunes who was
here and she went away Congress for a
little bit she's now back but she's on
Twitter so she knew all these people
associated with the Great Barrington uh
statement and a number of other coveted
and lockdown I think uh activities and
uh so they brought this problem to her
and we brought the changesi case and the
attorney generals of both Louisiana and
Missouri who had brought this case
looked at it you'll see the complaints
are very similar and uh they uh called
us and said you know we have this case
down here as well do you have anybody uh
you know who could join it and I thought
well yes we do and so uh Jay and Aaron
carrity and and Martin koldorf and Jill
Heinz all join this case and we
represent them all in Missouri V Biden
bringing up sort of different aspects
than the states can bring up on what the
problem is here you mentioned that a
focus of the new civil liberties
Alliance is taking cases against the
administrative State the overreach of
the administrative State could you
describe what is the key importance of
that mission to you why is why is that
an important front in protecting
Americans Liberties uh because we have a
constitution it has a separation of
powers there are things the executive is
supposed to do the Congress is supposed
to do and the judges the Judiciary is
supposed to do and what the
administrative state does and has been
pushed for doing for about a hundred
years is mush all these together so that
you lack the responsiveness that
Congress is supposed to have to the
people you lack the accountability the
president's supposed to have
um and his duty to enforce the laws as
written rather than as he's he'd like
them to be and oftentimes you have them
making uh Judiciary type decisions
without all all the pro all the
protections of due process so you you
really get around the Constitution if
you allow these administrative agencies
to get out of hand and this case is a is
a great example of it the con the the
First Amendment says that uh Congress
shall make no law abridging freedom of
speech right well
that abridgement it doesn't just mean
you know that that they can't pass a law
but it also means the government can't
abridge those by doing other things and
in this case the administrative agencies
were on every social media platform
screaming at them to get certain
messages and actual individual people
off the new Public Square and they don't
have any remit for this the way we got
involved in the shangisi case was the
Surgeon General is sending requests for
production to all these social media
companies what they're putting out there
about covid and about the vaccines well
you can read every every little statute
about the Surgeon General does he
doesn't have any power to do that he
can't be telling social media companies
what to do he has a uniform and a
platform he doesn't have he doesn't have
the ability to take documents from these
places or to threaten them but with the
administrative State behind him he does
we're gonna get into all of that uh
trying to figure out what what those
boundaries are and whether or not the
administrative State uh overstepped them
and we're going to look at the documents
we're going to look at the case uh uh
the cases complaint we're going to play
some clips but before we start digging
into that material Jay what are you
personally hoping gets accomplished in
this case as a plaintiff who is saying
that you were directly affected by it
uh my my primary goal in this case is to
restore free speech so that science can
actually function again uh I think
during the pandemic what we've seen is
that the uh the the federal government
agencies uh use their muscle and power
to elevate one brand of science I I
believe a deeply flawed brand of science
that made tremendous mistakes about you
know masking toddlers or or or whatnot
um but in order to get their way rather
than apply reason apply rather than uh
fund rigorous studies to test hypotheses
instead what they did is they
effectively uh smothered the voices of
people who were criticizing their own
misinformation in the name of
suppressing misinformation
um you know and and we're talking about
federal government agencies uh John
mentioned the office of Surgeon General
but also if you if you look it was the
National Institute of Health who ordered
the devastating takedown of the great
branching declaration it was it was uh
the CDC it was the the White House
itself
directly involved in threatening social
media companies telling them who to
censor and what to censor simply because
they were being criticized by outside
critics that they didn't that with whom
they disagreed uh I mean you know the
White House already has a bully pulpit
they could have said we don't agree with
these scientists on these facts fine uh
what they did instead was they went to
the social media company and said if you
allow these scientists to say these
things if you allow these ideas to go on
your platform we're going to go after
you we're going to attack you uh what I
would like from this case is the third
to be a bright line so that no
government agency ever again decides
that it has the power to suppress
scientific discussion in this country I
think I think it's a fundamental and
vital for scientific science to function
that the government agencies that have
an invested interest in people believing
their view of science not be allowed to
censor outside critics and uh if we can
get that I'll be I'll view this as an
enormous victory
but let's see if we can find that bright
line and to do so let's start with the
biggest let's zoom out and start with
the big picture just to see what what
are the kind of the big constitutional
questions at stake here uh this is the
case uh and it's a as you can see these
are uh the defendants uh this is just
the first three pages of defendants
there's uh three and a half more pages
uh it's a real you know Rogues Gallery
here going from Biden to the Surgeon
General to every single spokesperson uh
to the cyber security and infrastructure
Security Agency so uh you know no one
there's seemingly no part of the federal
government uh Untouched by this case uh
because they were all involved in
regulating uh the flow of information
misinformation disinformation uh from
this time period from 2016 approximately
2016 to I guess present
um Missouri uh this is from the
complaint here are some of the specific
instances of what you call social media
censorship in the complaint one the
hunter Biden laptop story to speech
about the lab leak theory of covid19's
Origins
three speech about the efficacy of mask
mandates and covid-19 lockdowns and four
speech about election integrity and the
security of voting by mail and we'll try
to get to all of these I'm not sure if
we will but uh we'll just take them one
by one this is the legal principle that
you articulate uh you're citing a case
called Biden V night First Amendment
Institute at Columbia University and it
says that uh the the quote from Justice
Thomas concurring is that the government
cannot accomplish through threats of
adverse government action what the
Constitution prohibits it from doing
directly
John is that what you're arguing
happened in this case and if so how it
is so the way these cases have come
about is that some people sue the social
media companies they say you've you've
uh you've shut off my my uh Speech and
you've hurt me in that way well the
traditional view of the law is that uh
if I run a newspaper I don't have to run
your articles I don't have to they have
their own free speech rights right so
they can do what they want if they're
unaffected by the government
but what we found over the years and it
came up in um Bookseller cases and
places like this is that the sheriff or
the local authorities would go in and
say look we're going to crack down on
you if you don't get rid of this book
and that book and the other book
um or just just come by repeatedly and
say you know we really don't like these
books here in our town we we don't think
you should carry those and there's some
bad people who are gonna who are going
to read these books and do bad things
and not and then the threat is an overt
and in those cases the Supreme Court has
said look you can't do that that is a
that is a threatening
um a threatening act that you have no
legal right to do if Congress said we're
going to remove those books we all know
that's not allowed right so the the
executive can't go around and getting
the same result through
um through means of either intimidation
or overly pressuring them just just
constantly being in their face
and the the one of the cases I noticed
that was cited was the case of Backpage
which has been covered extensively here
at Reason by Elizabeth Nolan Brown and
Paul Dietrich uh about the way that you
know local law enforcement strong armed
this publication because they didn't
like that they were publishing ads that
they went to the checking they went to
the credit card people who funded them
right so right so how was that yeah just
to explain a little bit more how that's
pertinent to this case so there what
they did was they they went to the
credit card companies and they said that
these are all uh lender risk and this
type of thing and we have great concerns
with this um Backpage had had like
prostitution and and I think child
trafficking I think was the allegation
but they didn't go after them for that
they didn't take the prostitution and
the and the child trafficking laws and
go after Backpage they went to the to
the um checking uh the credit card
companies and said we think this is risk
for them and we really think you
shouldn't you shouldn't allow your um
services for back page and that has the
effect of taking back page down and that
was again they were really trying to
abridge speech they weren't trying to
enforce the laws that they had that they
could have gone and done
and uh just before we I want to ask Jay
about a specific instance of social
media takedown that he experienced but
before moving to that one more point on
just kind of the the Big Frame of the
case which is called Missouri V Biden
this is not this started under Trump as
a lot of people have pointed out to me
since we started kind of promoting this
stream
um this is not a partisan thing you know
the the kind of administrative state is
consistent from one Administration to
another it's just that Biden right now
is the president so he's the named
defendant is that more or less correct
yeah do you want me to take that oh yeah
yeah
that is exactly correct so this goes to
the administrative State issue right
most of what uh Jay's talking about with
NIH and CDC all happened under Trump and
he had given it appears um a lot of
running room to Dr fauci and and to the
heads of CDC and you saw the
administrative agencies kind of
directing this stuff without without a
lot of uh pushback from from the the
White House and those in those
circumstances so I do think that this is
an administrative State problem NADA
who's an office problem and and they
they then went about uh
being the the world's Authority on
everything and that that's fine they can
say they're the world's Authority and we
know best but what they can say is so
shut up that guy who differs from my
view is the world Authority
and you know and one one more detail
just to to touch on before we get to Jay
here is that a uh uh U.S District Court
on July 4th of this year actually
granted you all the preliminary
injunction and what they've said there
was that uh that uh
all of these government employees are
restrained from the following actions as
to social media companies meeting with
social media companies for the purpose
of encouraging them to remove content
flagging content urging them to do any
of this emailing them collaborating
threatening basically any sort of back
and forth was prohibited by this judge
and now just last week uh the fir the
appeal to that was heard so what is the
status of things right now is the
government allowed to continue this job
owning as this uh kind of plays itself
out or
um it was was that lifted it was there
was in so it was in existence for about
a week and then and then an
administrative the government the day
after July 4th this was issued on July
4th by judge Dowdy I think to send a
message and uh and the day after
government appealed so from July 5th and
that was just don't argue before the
fifth circuit on August 10th that is
lightning fast in the legal business
um but what the fifth circuit did was
they issued an administrative stay of
the injunction what that means is we
don't we're not doing anything on the
merits but you guys just dropped
hundreds of pages of briefs on us and we
need administratively time to read this
stuff and we're going to stay it there
not anything having to do with the
merits having to do how judges have to
do work
yeah and you mentioned in that yeah in
the previous answer when we were talking
about uh this this all started obviously
under the Trump Administration that's
the majority of what uh Jay experienced
when he was speaking out against covet
policies
um there's one particular instance I
want to zoom in on in which you appeared
in a video uh with Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis and several epidemiologists for
Roundtable and this was in March 2021
that video was removed by YouTube we're
gonna play a clip from it right now and
I want to get your Reflections on what
happened there
I think the lockdowns are the single
biggest Public Health mistake in history
I think the lockdowns have have uh as
Martin said have failed to protect the
vulnerable uh Dr Gupta mentioned about
you know not putting masks on kids
that's not effective not necessary uh
Martin folder do you agree in school
there's no no need for them to be
wearing face masks uh children should
not wear face masks no there's uh they
don't need it for their own protection
and they don't need it for protecting
other people either
okay I mean I think schools how do you
teach a child to read with face masks on
on Zoom or you know I think I think the
um the children develop by watching
other people and I I think it's
development developmentally
inappropriate and it just doesn't help
on the on the Z spread I think it's
absolutely not the right thing to do
so I mean the the Striking thing looking
in the rear view mirror is that this is
more or less what I think reasonable
people agree with at this point
especially the mask point I mean that
that became policy in Florida shortly
after this and
there wasn't some sort of explosion of
you know childhood deaths or deaths in
schools but putting that aside the
reason I I play included the mask part
is that that's what YouTube said was
their reason for removing that video
from their platform what was your
reaction when that happened back in
March of 2021
I mean I was incensed I mean Zach I I
had before I prepared for that event uh
that got what the governor had invited
me to come out by looking at the
literature on child masking and I
couldn't find a single randomized study
that demonstrated in fact there was no
evaluation no randomized value from
Child masking at all and the the
evaluation of masking the the high
quality randomized evaluations of
masking of adults uh preventing for
instance the spread of the flu had found
nothing uh same thing was for covet
specifically there was this Danish study
this randomized Danish study that found
no ability of the mass in adults for
surgical Mass versus versus no mask uh
uh for stopping you from getting covered
no statistic significant effect
um and so I mean I knew that there was a
that there was no support a high quality
data in the literature about this and I
also had heard from so many parents from
you know autistic of autistic kids of
hearing impaired kids telling me that
their kids were suffering because of the
of the uh these requirements for masking
so I was pretty comp confident that I
was right scientifically when I made
that statement of course you're doing it
in public so you have to do it in a way
that's that's accessible to people
um and I don't think what I said was
wrong there certainly it's within the
realm of scientific discussion of you
know to have that and so when YouTube
suppressed that video of a sitting
Governor talking to a scientific
advisors in public so he so that the
public can understand the scientific
basis for which he's making decisions
I was stunned I mean I thought I I like
I thought like good government groups
should be fair or that even if you
disagree with what I said at least you
want to know what the advice the
governor is getting right that should be
public
um it's within the scientific bounds
like there's I knew there was scientific
disagreement about this uh although in
retrospect there shouldn't have been any
like it was really really clear that
there was no good strong evidence in
favor of the masking at all in fact not
even not even real even though the weak
evidence was not convincing the weak
evidence being like bad correlational
studies
um so uh I I I I still am stunned to
this Zach I can't understand
um and you know the effect of it wasn't
that you couldn't see the video the
effect of it really was to defame me and
and other scientists who disagreed with
the government
about these masking studies the whole
the whole purpose was to say well look
these guys are free and scientists so
Fringe that it's dangerous to have their
views even up on YouTube
um it was and you know it's it's um
looking back uh I mean I blame YouTube
at the time I didn't understand at the
time that the government itself had a
had a had a a big you know sort of push
to try to get this kind of message off
YouTube because they didn't want their
policies to be criticized
yes and that that's what the heart of
this case is is trying to kind of uh
examine exactly what the government's
involvement behind the scenes was and
whether they stepped over that line and
where it start where that that
interaction starts to get revealed is in
another example that you were involved
with which is you butting heads with
Anthony fauci and Francis Collins well I
shouldn't even say butting heads because
this was all going on in you know
private emails that were later revealed
but this is a headline from October 2020
where uh Dr fauci says letting the
coronavirus spread to achieve herd
immunity is nonsense and dangerous he
said uh this a version of this to
several media Outlets during this time
period
um and you all uh John uh deposed uh Dr
fauci and I've pulled a clip from that
deposition where he talks about his
reaction to
um the the Great Barrington declaration
which was a a letter that you and
several other uh scientists uh signed uh
Jay which basically said that lockdowns
aren't working they're detrimental a
better strategy would be what you call
what you called Focus protection where
you try to Shield the most vulnerable
people from the virus as much as
possible
will you let other people kind of live
their lives fauci thought that was a
dangerous and nonsense idea and this is
what he had to say when questioned in
deposition about about that time period
let's roll that clip for a second
as Dr fauci says letting the coronavirus
spread to achieve herdy immunity is
quote nonsense and quote dangerous
correct that is correct you believe do
you still believe that do I believe that
the Barrington
decoration premise of letting the virus
rip through society and infect people
leading to their illness hospitalization
and death
is nonsense and dangerous
I still do are you an epidemiologist
I'm an infectious disease person with
some pretty good experience in
epidemiology our doctor is Doctor about
acharya an epidemiologist I don't know I
guess you'll have to look up as
credentials so your statement was made
within two days of Dr Collins's
statement to The Washington Post correct
right uh did you guys coordinate on
making those statements did you discuss
it with each other that you're going to
make these statements criticizing the
Great Barrington declaration other than
the emails you've already seen I don't
believe so but I'm not one no I don't
that's not a style to be coordinating
things but I don't know it's possible we
discussed it depends on what your
definition of coordination is and the
same time frame did you become aware
that the Great Barrington Declaration
was being censored in social media
I'm not aware of any censorship of of
anything like I said
multiple times and I'll repeat it again
for the record I don't follow
what goes on on social media censoring
or otherwise that's not something that I
pay attention to
okay so two questions out of that first
one for Jay
just your
immediate reaction to What voucher is
saying there in this deposition
it's propaganda Zach it's absolute
propaganda so as you said as you
described it is the inaccurate
description of what we did said and
wrote in the great branch of Declaration
we were not calling for letting the
virus rip uh and and the evidence was
very clear that the lockdowns especially
in the spring have not failed to protect
older and vulnerable people from there
many many many older vulnerable people
that died from the virus despite the
lockdowns uh there was the counter
example of Sweden which had which had
better outcomes in much of the rest of
Europe and certainly much of the rest of
the United States
um which had not locked down they're not
closed schools had had
adopted more reasonable protection of
what making a priority to pack
vulnerable older people the strategies
that that that Dr fauci had espoused at
the time had failed and it had caused
tremendous damage to the poor the
children the working class at the time
in the summer of 2020 there were
estimates that a hundred million people
would be thrown into poverty worldwide
because the economic education caused by
Dr fauci's lockdowns 130 million people
coding the world food program in the U.N
we're going to be we're at risk of dire
food insecurity meaning starvation
the lockdowns were tremendously damaging
the health of the of the world and Dr
fauci uh rather than trying to Grapple
with the actual critique we had uh
essentially organized a propaganda
campaign you can see when that CNBC
thing he went around saying that we want
that he set up a straw man said oh let
the virus rip
um no that was not we were not calling
for letting the virus we were calling
for better protection of vulnerable
older people we were not taking
seriously enough
and it was dangerous to let the
lockdowns continue which unfortunately
we did
uh now and then that deposition is so
interesting
um he denies or initially talking or
coordinating with Collins even though
the language they used was almost
identical nonsense he says then he
realizes I guess that he's under oath
and backtracks right in real time you
see that in real time he says oh well
maybe I might have spoken I don't
remember I think I think and and then
when he's asked about censorship he's
like oh I don't I don't read social
media as if that's responsive to the
question
um
179 times in that deposition he says I
don't recall
on basic scientific matters on on like
conversations and even when he has
emails put in front of he doesn't I'm
sure he's a very busy man uh but it it
Beggars the imagination to think that he
he uh who is a architect of the lockdown
policies that we followed recalls so few
of the details of the key key uh key
sort of moments around this
um I mean I I'm I was stunned watching
that deposition and I think anyone that
watches it with an open mind can say
look we were not LED well by the
government scientists during the
pandemic
and John picking up on that point of
whether or not there was coordination
here which fauci says they were not
coordinating or it kind of depends on
what you mean by coordinating I mean we
do know because of these emails that
there was the call for the quick and
devastating takedown and then as uh Jay
just mentioned there was some similar
language uh kind of put out there into
the media
is that evidence to you of coordination
um and if so does that actually kind of
approach the line of uh you know
illegally suppressing speech uh even if
they were coordinating he goes they went
way over that lie because there's other
things going on here he's talking to
Francis Colin they have an email email
says we got to take down the Great
Barrington it's not a it's not like I'm
I'm I have like some sort of uh
suspicion here I've got the email where
they say that right and he's conflict
with that and so Collins is is
um out there pushing these things down
and CDC
has a meeting with the social media I
that was that deposition was taken by
John Sauer that's the voice you hear
there and he doesn't push back on fauci
he lets him go because John Sauer knows
as well as I and Jay know that the Great
Barrington declaration didn't say let
her rip that was the propaganda that
that Collins and bouchi were putting out
there and then the CDC was telling
YouTube and everyone else that this
letter rip thing is very dangerous and
you got to take it down now fauci did
not to my knowledge he wasn't in those
meetings but CDC was who was under I
think Collins was there so so yeah of
course they were coordinating this this
was what was is called a whole of
government effort so every single agency
that could was taking part in it and so
the idea that there's no coordination
when every single agency is doing this
and meeting many times with these um
with these social media companies is
simply wrong and the the idea that fauci
wasn't trying with the CDC that the head
of the CDC communicate patients with the
social media she said at her deposition
I was trying to downgrade these other
messages I because I I asked did you try
to get them removed she said I think she
said either remove or downgraded way
down so people didn't see them so it's
not it's not um it's not speculation
they said they were doing this they they
said that it's good and they said
they'll do it again that's what's going
on well let's look at how that whole of
government effort functioned at least
according to your argument and by the
way I promise all of our viewers and
listeners that we're going to be
bringing up some of the counter
arguments to have you respond to them I
actually have some of the oral arguments
so you'll be able to respond directly to
uh what the other side is saying but
first I just want to lay out your case a
little bit more clearly and with this
whole of government effort part of what
you're saying in uh the complaint is
that during a certain time period the
CDC and the entire the Biden
administration's uh staff the entire
kind of federal Public Health apparatus
was geared towards
doing everything it could to pressure
the social media companies to kind of
you know apply the boots on the neck or
you know hang the sort of Damocles or
whatever metaphor you want to use uh
over them and we're just going to play a
couple Clips to kind of illustrate or
remind people of what was going on
publicly during that time period and and
the first clip is this famous one of
Biden uh saying that the social media
companies are literally leading to
people dying so let's play that clip
real quick
to circulate online they're killing
people
I mean it really they don't look the
only pandemic we have is among the
unvaccinated
yeah and then during uh you know around
that same time period this is when uh
Vivek Murthy the Surgeon General at the
time was demanding data on covid-19
misinformation from major Tech firms so
he had put out you know I'm sure a very
friendly letter asking could you please
uh turn this stuff over to us and he had
also made a speech uh saying that
misinformation is actually a public
health Menace we've pulled that clip I
want to play that uh for a moment too
and then ask Jay to react to kind of the
public health messaging of the time
I issued a surgeon general's advisory
on the dangers of Health misinformation
Surgeon General advisories are reserved
for Urgent Public Health threats
and while those threats have often been
related to what we eat drink and smoke
today we live in a world where
misinformation poses an imminent and
Insidious threat to our nation's health
what do you think of that message that
was coming from the Surgeon General
Murphy at the at the time Jay is someone
who is in the field of Public Health
you know bad information obviously can
be bad for People's Health if they don't
follow the right advice what did you
think when you saw that
I thought it was a dangerous abuse of
his power I mean I think it is
absolutely right for the Surgeon General
to say here's what the scientific here's
our view of what the scientific evidence
says regarding you know sort of whatever
trans fats smoking whatever uh even for
covet here's my view here's our view of
the scientific evidence right
um but they but they have an obligation
to express what all of the science what
the range of scientists are saying not
not to take one view even in those kinds
of pronouncements they need to be much
more broad very broad-minded if they can
here it's even a step further right what
they're saying is that they are so right
that they're in their view about for
instance you know masking toddlers that
that anyone that says that masking
Towers doesn't work is spreading this
information that you should and it's
dangerous or or the VA or the vaccine
misinformation
um you know uh the idea that the vaccine
protects you against covid well you know
a lot of people even by that time were
starting to get coveted despite being
vaccinated
um they were very worried if you look at
the legal filings about that fact
getting out
uh you know there's a funny story in the
legal filings in Missouri versus Biden
that it turns out that that in fact the
White House itself was suppressed and
it's Facebook price page suppressed
because it was tagged as an anti-vaxx
group
um the White House was because in um I
think just a month later after that I
think after after that uh that piece um
in March the White House the the CDC put
out a warning that the Johnson Johnson
vaccine was causing Strokes in young in
in in middle-aged women
and uh paused the J J vacs my colleague
Martin kuldiff actually wrote an op-ed
saying that that CDC acted prematurely
you wrote a pro-vax column
the White House pressure on Facebook to
suppress anti-vatch propaganda caught
the White House up because it then put
the cdc's pause of the J J vacs up it
got tagged by the algorithms as an
anti-vaxx group and then you have emails
from Rob Flaherty of the White House
screaming at Facebook saying why are you
suppressing the spread of the of
information true information by the
White House
um you know they they basically created
an engine to try to to suppress honest
scientific discussion and vivec Murphy
uh I mean he's going to go down in
history as a as one of the most
irresponsible surgeon Generals in
history he was he himself was spreading
misinformation at the time he organized
a campaign to defame people who were
criticizing him for the uh the spread of
his misinformation
and and I'll just add I think the
algorithm also it they they had super
spreaders of misinformation coveted
misinformation and how many times you
posted was part of the algorithm so I
think it was either the Facebook or the
Instagram I forget which it was but
Biden's became a super spreader of
misinformation on the government website
in the very trap that they had set up to
shut up everyone else and when it
happened to them Jay's being very very
uh he said it very nicely uh Rob
Flaherty's emails are um our uh
sailor-like in their anger that this
happened so they set up this net to shut
everyone else up it caught them and they
were unhappy with it
and it's very well established at this
point that there was an ongoing
relationship between these various
federal agencies and the social media
companies in light of the Twitter files
the Facebook uh Revelations that Robbie
Suave had reason is reported on um and
that we've covered here on the stream
um this what what Jacob Siegel calls the
counter disinformation complex uh I
encourage anyone interested in the stuff
to watch any of those conversations that
we've previously had the question that
this uh this lawsuit is trying to get to
is what when does that sort of
collaboration
become a kind of involuntary
suppression of speech uh that that the
the social media companies are forced to
do on behalf of the government
um you know while we're talking about
perfect Murthy uh AF this is from the
complaint it said that it says that
after President Biden stated that
Facebook was killing people a senior
executive at meta reached out to Murthy
to engage in damage control and appease
the president's wrath
um and that he sent text messages to him
noting it's not great to be accused of
killing people and expressing he was
Keen to find a way to de-es escalate and
work together collaboratively now in a
second we're going to get to some of the
possible threats that were being held
against these companies but just in a
hypothetical sense would these kind of
interactions in your opinion John be
illegal would they be crossing a line to
just be kind of having an open Channel
between the government and social media
companies and social media companies
saying hey we don't want bad information
harmful stuff all of our platforms it's
useful to us to consult with the CDC or
NIH or whoever else well I noticed this
I notice it's not them making the calls
the government's always calling but so I
think there's I think that even there
there is a coercion of some sort because
it is the government but if
you get information government the
government can provide information to
people the way it does to you or me but
I'll give an example during the Cold War
a lot of times the New York Times The
Washington Post or somebody would get
information about spies right or
something that was going on in a foreign
country and they would they would call
the White House or they'd call the CIA
or whatever and say we're going to put
out a newspaper story and and the the
CIA would say look we got to get our guy
out of there can you delay for two days
three days whatever it was and um the
papers would do that voluntarily there
wasn't really a threat towards them or
anything they just didn't want to get
any uh American asset kill so if it's
that sort of thing it's not a problem
but here it is constantly calling them
um I I do think there's a difference
between or they could put it on their
website the CDC or NIH they have
websites they could put any information
there and if the and if that were the
case if the social media just read their
websites and said you know what I agree
with the government I'm going to do that
that would be a different story but
that's not what's happening here it's
very interesting that you you mentioned
the Twitter files but we had all this
discovery we got in this case as well
none of this stuff was out in the open
they didn't tell the regular public they
were doing this in the chicken when we
first brought these cases here at new
civil liberties we had to look what's
happening with Murphy wait what are they
doing why is this happening is this just
a coincidence you know we didn't have
the actual emails or meetings or all
that that we have now uh so it wasn't
like they were telling anybody this is
what I'm doing so people like Jay or
people I wasn't on social media then
they all thought it was just these
social media companies so that is
another problem here yeah that I mean
that's what really piqued my interest
about this case is a lot of the
discussion uh in past years has been
about are there things that can be done
to like kind of bend the social media
companies to our will and make them
moderate new neutrally and I know that's
part of your lawsuit and I want to talk
about that a little bit but the main
part of your lawsuit it has to do I mean
you're the the defendants in your
lawsuit are government actors it's not
the social media companies and I think
you're it's very clearly seeing that
this was uh what you're going after is
the what you're alleging is the coercion
in this case and I think that is really
uh the right place to be focused uh and
uh we're going to talk about some of the
coercive tactics in just a second that
you lay out but first I just want to
bring up a couple audience questions uh
one is Claude Asher saying is anyone in
control of the administrative State
um also Claude said it covet is just the
start
um I guess to for both those questions
you know I I wanna
leave it open to either of you to jump
in here but
how I guess for John first since you're
the one who is with the law firm that
goes after the administrative State how
much more difficult or easy is it to
hold the administrative State
accountable than say elected politicians
so it's difficult at least the electric
politicians
um can be voted out you can't vote out
any of these bureaucrats
um and and that is the that is the
problem I think that they can be
controlled by an active executive but we
did we haven't really seen that in covid
we've either seen
um let them do what they want or we said
seeing help them I do want to something
that you just said does remind me though
I think everyone who got into this
thought well it's Silicon Valley they
probably want to keep certain views out
because they're all a mono a mono
culture with all the same views right
and all that we didn't find that I mean
all the lawyers on this case I think
have been kind of stunned that Facebook
was pushing back
um you they were all poking pushing back
in fact at one point Facebook said well
you know in the scientific area you're
probably hurting this because if if
you're wrong that things won't get out
and also you'll make people paranoid if
they find out that you're keeping being
views down Facebook's telling like
straight first amendment stuff they're
telling the government the government's
yelling at them about it so it was not
the case and I think that makes the our
case stronger that these companies roll
like yeah we want to do this we'd be
doing this without this pressure without
these calls and these threats well let's
talk about what they yeah please do uh
yeah it's just real fast so I think I
think the the key thing here is is that
the government that the public trust in
the government had collapsed uh
certainly by the during the Trump
Administration but then but then during
the by Administration it had utterly
collapsed why is Murphy sitting there is
talking about suppressing uh speech on
on Facebook because people don't believe
him right people don't people do not
trust him people don't trust the
government people don't why is Anthony
fauci looking like he's a you know used
car salesman in in that deposition
um you know but denying the obvious fact
that he spoke with Collins it's because
people didn't trust him anymore
uh the the recourse to this kind of
coercive power this suppression and
violation of First Amendment rights
happened because the government failed
to Garner the trust of the American
public
and they are they're they're they're
they're acting in this way because they
they they they they don't know how else
to regain the trust if if instead what
they had done is that engaged with the
outside critics you know sort of maybe
done with the governor of Florida did
like have a have a round table except
bring more people in you know have a
like I remember one point during the uh
2008 uh debate over over Obamacare there
was a fantastic uh discussion between
you know uh opposing points of view
overseen by the president of the United
States right uh have that debate openly
uh with Scientists on on like have have
Martin koldorf and and Tony facci in the
same room
televised right that would have
engendered much more trust rather than
what they ended up doing so with the
reason why they're doing this is because
their
their propaganda campaign had failed to
convince most of the American public
they were right if they were so right if
the scientific governments on their side
they wouldn't need to engage in coercion
they could just sit they could just
point the scientific evidence they look
it works this is what works that they
couldn't do that
so what would your lesson be from that
uh say you know God forbid another
pandemic hits or there's some sort of
emergency where people are afraid and
they just want a simple answer uh that
and they're you know the I I think that
a lot of this comes from like there's
this fog of confusion with all the
information that's out there and uh the
the way the people in the government
were thinking was like we just need to
have like the one answer and kind of
push all this stuff other stuff down
because we're in an emergency
um how what what would be a better way
to react to an emergency the next
emergency
I mean I don't think that you should be
looking for gurus that have the the
answer as soon as you find somebody who
says to you uh if you contradict me
you're not contradicting a man you're
Contracting science itself well that
that person you shouldn't be trusting
in a complicated situation like this you
need a very very wide array of voices
some of whom are going to disagree with
each other
uh I if I were in charge of the uh
messaging and decision making around at
the CDC or at the NIH or where elsewhere
what I would have done is I would
Embrace that fact and treated the
American public like adults uh I would
have told them here's what we know
here's what we don't know here's where
it's complicated here's and I certainly
wouldn't have fear-mongered fear is
natural response to the threat of a
virus like this it is it's it's
completely understandable the job of
Public Health is to push back against
that fear to say here's what we know
here's what we're doing to develop
information uh to provide good
information when it's when it's rock
solid
um and then and then to embrace the
ambiguity when it's that's what the the
science is saying uh to embrace the the
the the cacophony of voices as opposed
to and then you know of course they can
have their view too I think treating the
American public like adults would have
been far better would have engendered
more trust and we would have gotten
better results uh where you know than we
did which is essentially by saying look
uh Tony fauci's view is the only view
that matters everyone else's
misinformation that by itself I think is
responsible for a tremendous amount of
the damage that happened during the
pandemic you know I mean especially in
the digital age where we have uh all the
digital receipts and everyone's you know
Collective memory so to speak is much
longer because you can just go back and
look at what people said and compare it
to the reality of what played out I do
want to turn to the mechanism that
you're alleging was used to strong arm
or Jawbone these companies into
submission and that happens to be
section 230 of the communications
decency act which we've covered a lot at
reason we are kind of defenders in
principle of what it's trying to
accomplish just to remind people what it
is uh sorry this is the wrong slide uh
there's a section where you you have it
summarized here in the complaint uh it
says that no provider or user of an
interactive Computer Service should be
held liable on account of any action
voluntarily taken in good faith to
restrict access to or availability of
material that the provider or user
considers to be obscene lewd lascivious
filthy excessively violent harassing or
otherwise objectionable
in summary uh section 230 says that
platforms cannot be held liable for user
generated content as long as it's lawful
speech and
um that has given them a lot of ability
to grow because it would be pretty much
impossible to run a social network if
you had to be constantly checking
everything that someone posted to make
sure it's not defaming somebody or you
know making some sort of uh uh you know
comment that someone's going to sue you
the provider over and that is uh
something so it's essential to the
existence of these platforms and it's
something that Biden and his team uh
over this time period has consistently
and continually said they want to take a
look at and they have said it under
circumstances where it's quite close to
where they're talking about they don't
like the behavior that these platforms
are engaging in or what they're allowing
to proliferate so let's start with a a
clip of candidate Biden in January 2020
uh saying this to the New York Times
editorial board
Mr Vice President in October your
campaign sent a letter to Facebook
regarding an ad that falsely claimed
that you blackmailed Ukrainian officials
to not investigate your son and I'm
curious did that experience dealing with
Facebook and
their power did that change the way that
you see the power of tech platforms
right now no I've never been a fan of
Facebook as you probably know I've never
been a big Zuckerberg fan I think he's a
real problem
them being exempt which you're not
exempt you can't write something you're
knowing to be false and being exempt
from being sued but he can't section 230
should be revoked immediately should be
revoked number one for Zuckerberg and
other platforms that's a pretty
foundational love of the modern that's
right it's internet exactly right and it
should be revoked
it should be revoked
because it is not merely an internet
company it is propagating falsehoods
they know to be false and we should be
setting standards not unlike the
Europeans are doing it relative to
privacy you guys still have editors I'm
sitting with them not a joke there is no
editorial impact at all on Facebook none
none whatsoever it's irresponsible it's
totally irresponsible if if there's
proven harm that that Facebook has done
should someone like Mark Zuckerberg be
uh submitted to criminal penalties
perhaps
he should be submitted to civil
liability in his company to civil
liability just like you would be
here at the New York Times
so there's uh Biden coming in hot
Zuckerberg that has a real problem uh
and then once he got in office I've got
two clips from his press secretary that
I want to play in succession uh the
first is uh from around that same time
period uh when uh yes from jensaki it's
from around that same uh time period uh
that the Murthy statement came out so
let's play that one first
uh jensaki really likes uh section 230.
or actions Alex that we have taken or
we're working to take I should say from
the federal government we've increased
disinformation research and tracking
within the surgeon general's office
we're flagging problematic
sorry that's actually the wrong clip
could you play the once as yeah sucky
Anti-Trust please Bess
that
um the major platforms uh have a
responsibility uh related to the health
and safety of all Americans uh to stop
amplifying untrustworthy content
disinformation and misinformation
especially related to covid-19
vaccinations and elections and we've
seen that over the past several months
broadly speaking I'm not placing any
blame on any individual or group we've
seen it from a number of sources he also
supports better privacy protections and
a robust Anti-Trust program so his view
is that there's more that needs to be
done to ensure that this type of
misinformation disinformation damaging
sometimes life-threatening information
is not going out to the American public
okay and so there she is uh that was in
May 2021 uh saying that you know we have
a real problem with the kind of
information they're letting flourish it
would be a shame if we took a look at
section 230 and also some Anti-Trust
action that's really at the front of our
minds uh strangely in 2022 that same
pair came up after uh Elon Musk
purchased Twitter and said that he
wasn't going to be suppressing that sort
of information anymore let's play that
clip for a moment
breaking news Twitter agreeing to let
Elon Musk purchase make this go through
this purchase do you have a response to
that and does the White House have any
concern that this new agreement might
have President Trump back on the
platform well I'm not going to comment
on a specific transaction uh what I can
tell you is a general matter no matter
who owns or runs uh Twitter uh the
president has long been concerned about
the power of large social media
platforms uh what they have that power
they have over our everyday lives has
long argued that Tech platforms must be
held accountable for the harms they
cause he's been a strong supporter of
fundamental reforms to achieve that goal
including reforms to section 230
enacting Anti-Trust reforms requiring
more transparency and more and he's
encouraged that there's bipartisan
interest in Congress
so
clearly there's it's like a reflex
whenever we're talking about
misinformation we're going to bring up
you know this threat of section 230
reform and Anti-Trust I guess my
question for you John is is that really
illegal though or is that just kind of
using the bully pulpit in a way that's
First Amendment protected
does it abridge speech I think it does I
think that you're bringing to bear this
is worth billions 230 is worth billions
to these companies and the fact that
there's bipartisan anger over it and I'd
never seen that clip of Biden you just
ran
um that is that is even more explicit uh
maybe it'll be in my next brief but I I
think that I think that uh what what you
have here is it's it's a threat to take
away billions of dollars from these
corporations and to change their whole
way they work and even if you can't get
Congress go along here you can then you
can have Republicans in those clips on
230 by the way as well and um but the
administration itself can take positions
it can have the justice department take
a position that 230 doesn't cover this
or 230 doesn't cover that that's a huge
headache for these so you don't even
need to pass legislation so it's it's a
it's a huge threat as they as as the
fifth circuit judges were asking you
know nice social media company you have
there shame if any things gonna happen
to it and I so I think that it is when
you look at this whole of government and
the whole of the threat this is not a
one-off this is not you know uh JFK
calling in the steel guys and saying you
know steel prices are a little high can
you guys watch it or something one time
this is the administration contacting
them every day every week constantly
so then would your argument be then that
they should just never be able to make
those sort of statements that these are
actually kind of illegal veiled threats
so uh the the argument is is that they
first of all this doesn't cover Biden
right the the courts are not going to
tell the president what to say or not
say so Biden would still say what he's
going to say on your clips and and
that'll go in but but that can then be
used that the agencies are doing this
that or the other thing for this reason
yeah but yes the fact that they're
contacting these com these companies to
tell them who to keep on and who to keep
off is the problem not that they have
their own views you know we depose the
CDC I don't know what's going to come
out about the census but they got these
portals into all the um social media
companies during the census the census
wanted to get its message out to
communities that were afraid of the
census coming there so they'd say look
we don't do this we don't do immigration
we don't do all these things and the
social media platforms gave them these
portals so that they could get their
messages out onto the portals and and
and learn how to get it higher are up
that wasn't a problem we have never
heard that the Census Bureau had people
take down don't answer the door you know
um but it was then metastasized when
covet came along and this this portal
and this idea of hey we don't really
know much about social media how do we
get our message out there turn to how do
we stop these people's messages and
that's the problem when they're saying I
don't like this message take it down
that's what's that's what the problem is
and Jay you know we got a back door look
via the Twitter files that kind of how
the the dials are turned to turn
people's engagement Up and Down based on
what they're saying that goes against
the approved message and you were one of
the specific examples of someone who was
Shadow banned I mean Shadow Banning was
uh kind of considered a conspiracy
theory but you you actually were
suppressed uh according to these uh the
the material that Elon Musk turned over
you know seeing that and especially in
light of what's been uncovered in
Discovery for this case what's your
reaction been knowing that there's been
a concerted effort you know from the top
down to
really Target you
I mean I I now know what it felt like
for the the like the people accused of
being communists in the 1950s like I
mean literally uh in Facebook I was by
I'm Sorry by Twitter I was invited by uh
Elon Musk to go see Twitter headquarters
and see the the database for my account
um and it had the words Blacklist on
there I was blacklisted and it turns out
I was blacklisted the day I joined
Twitter in August 2021. what would cause
Twitter to decide that I was going to be
blacklisted in August 2020 before I even
I mean from the first day the first post
I think with the first or second post I
had was the Great Barrington declaration
and why I was put on a blacklist
um I mean it's it's absolutely stunning
and I don't think Twitter did it on
their own I mean their interest is to
get as many ideas out there as possible
their interest isn't to like Blacklist
scientists
um the the what happened here was the
government abused its power essentially
forcing these companies to to act to
spread the propaganda of government
scientists to suppress the speech of
people who disagreed with them
um I mean I still am stunned that this
happened in the United States I'd never
I mean I'm an immigrant to this country
I came when I was four I always thought
that this was the one place on Earth
where Free Speech was never going to be
violated and yet I find myself the
victim of of uh essentially a government
action to suppress Free Speech actually
can I say one other thing uh Zach before
I let you go back
um it was really interesting watching
that New York Times clip that taught
with President Biden and then and then
and then it's seeing what the the the
the reporters asked Jen saki about about
these these violence Free Speech
violations
the newspapers have an interest in
basically emasculating the social media
companies who are essentially their
competitors
if the social media companies are not a
bashed in a free speech well that means
that you will you will listen more to
the newspapers that's the only place we
can get information from it's like in
the in the Soviet Union the the the the
government suppressed Free Speech it's
such a great extent that that people
would you know they would they would
listen to Providence to see what the
government wanted them to think and then
there were these Sama stock like people
would send out secret messages
underneath uh uh you know essentially
trying to like get with the truth out uh
person to person under outside of the
view of the government essentially what
the what the newspapers want like the
New York Times is to kill a competitor
so that these Sama stock can't go out
the people will get their official View
and then view that as as authoritative
um so what you're seeing here is like a
lot of actors wanting to suppress free
speech and the government absolutely
using its muscle to try to destroy
social media in order to get its message
out in order to suppress if uh the
ability of outside critics to criticize
it it's entire entirely anti-American I
mean the I mean I I was put on a
blacklist Sac the word Blacklist was
there in the in the uh I just I just I
thought that was something that went
belonged in American history not not not
modern day times content modification
content modification that's the word
they use instead it said Blacklist John
and I I mean I think your your point is
uh one well worth considering and just
the media landscape that the you know
big large Publications are now competing
with independent voices you know sub
stackers podcasters and so forth and so
yes there is a real competitive uh you
know playing field going on there and
people need to uh be aware of that and
raise an eyebrow and I'm not saying
everyone who's a misinformation or
disinformation reporter is just you know
a sort of an attack dog for their
company but uh you should at least have
some media literacy about this situation
that's I think got to be the solution to
a lot of this is just improved media
literacy across the board but that's a
little bit of a tangent and I wanted to
bring us home by having John respond to
a few of the arguments from the
opposition this is from the oral
arguments in the appeal to the
injunction uh August
yes
um and uh we're gonna play a few of the
clips uh the the first one is
well it the the attorneys uh raising a
point that I started to get into earlier
which is how do you really determine
that this is involuntary compliance
versus you know illegal government or
involuntary compliance versus you know
just the social media companies
trying to improve their product so let's
play that clip from the oral arguments
and have John reply
Facebook comes to the CDC and says we're
trying to figure out whether these posts
are true can you give us scientific
information that would bear on that
question it would surprise me if the
only way CDC would respond would be
publicly rather than privately well
isn't it true though that that
nation is sometimes lo and behold
Vindicated as true information ideas
that were labeled false or later proven
true
um you know if if that happens that
doesn't change the fact that if social
media companies are making
determinations whether we like it or not
they're making determinations about what
to include on their platforms and what
algorithms to use to make some of it
more prominent and less prominent and
the and the social media companies have
decided and there's there's basically no
evidence in the record that that this
decision was coerced by anybody they
decided that they wanted in some
circumstances to have those decisions be
informed by government experts views
about what was true or false or what was
harmful or not harmful that doesn't mean
they were turning over the reins to the
government they were asking the
government for information
so there's no evidence in the record
that this was coerced they were asking
for this information what's your
response uh there's not one instance
that I can find in the record of
Facebook or any of these companies
calling the government in the first
instance it's all left back and forth
after the governments told them what
they want and if they want information
from the CDC well why don't they just
get it the way I get it which is calling
there's not some special
um backdoor channel that you go to I go
look at the CDC or I call them up so I
think that if the fact pattern were that
Facebook or any of these companies had
called the government and say look
there's this new thing we're seeing do
you have any information on that and the
government said yes here's the
information we have
I don't think that there would be a
problem now there's a problem because of
the huge amount of evidence we have that
what they were doing was not just
providing neutral information of what
the government's view was but saying
this is our view get other views off or
else the or else was behind all of it
and the idea and and Mr Tenney did a
nice job there but he wasn't he didn't
have all these facts he's he's in the
Appellate level of Justice he hasn't
been doing this for a year and a half he
he just got involved 30 days ago and the
fact of the matter is is that there is
indeed
um plenty of evidence that the companies
didn't want to do this they were saying
no
um uh Facebook would say that didn't
Violet Twitter would say that didn't
violate our policies and they say oh no
take down RFK Jr we want him off he's a
super spreader well he hasn't violated
this Alex Berenson well he hasn't
violated our policies off we want him
out and they're like I don't know and
then at some point they actually uh they
actually break and start doing exactly
what the government wants so um and you
just you just heard Jay he went and
looked and it said Blacklist on his on
his uh on his uh you on his Twitter file
do you think they wanted to Blacklist
the renowned scientists sight unseen
because somebody at Twitter just didn't
like him no the government had said
these guys have bad views views by the
way and I didn't bring this up before
fauci used to believe the same things
about respiratory viruses as Jay
believes just somehow changed
there's uh you know you mentioned his
you know the the or else the implicit or
else uh or maybe it's explicit I'm not
sure but it that's another issue that
the government's attorney raises in
these oral arguments I want to play that
clip as well and have you answer him uh
as to directly what the threat being
leveled is let's play that clip
pressure that we're talking about is is
you know the government is generically
going to be angry the government might
make public statements against somebody
if you look at those materials they
reflect a back and forth Facebook
sometimes is willing to do what the
government wants and sometimes isn't the
way you say it is very you know we're
going to sit down and have a meeting or
we'll pass out some document but what
appears to be in the record are these I
write messages uh from time to time from
high-ranking government officials that
say you didn't do this yet and and
that's my uh toning down the language uh
you didn't do this yet well haven't you
done this yet and so it's like jump
how high
there was a back and forth sometimes it
was more friendly sometimes people got
more testy
um there there were circumstances in
which
um the everyone saw eye to eye there
were circumstances in which they
disagreed
if you were if you were saying we're
going to do this you know if you don't
do this we're going to impose some
penalty some government regulation or
sanction on you that's not the way you
would go about it you wouldn't say I'm
really mad you would just say do this or
else and the or else would be clear
there was no indication in this record
of what the or else is what are they
going to do
so we've talked about what some of the
High Level Threats might have been with
Section 230 and antitrust but what
Tenney seems to be saying there is in
all of these interactions there was
never that direct threat of like do this
or this is going to happen to your
company is that necessary for it to be
illegal it is not necessary and he's
also forgetting the carrots Zach
um there was something else that was
found so uh the the guy who is in charge
of Facebook going going back there is a
former British uh politician and at one
point he finally says Facebook's
resisting resisting resisting and then
he says when the government comes in and
wants some some uh some some message
taken down he says listen
we've got a lot of other fish to fly fry
with the with the administration why are
we fighting with him about this like all
the he's a British guy well all these
Americans first First Amendment rights
right is what are we doing this for
because we've got a lot of other things
we want out of the government and that's
the other thing that I haven't mentioned
um Nick clag is his name and Nick Clegg
had he knows that a big multi-billion
dollar company
um like Facebook has a lot of government
interests and those carrots of what
they're asking for for either
um uh
under the administrative State you know
they have administrative agencies they
have to do what deal with they didn't
want to be getting crosswise for these
other asks they were going to make so I
we've brought up the threat but don't
forget about the carrots all the things
the government can do for a big company
to make its its uh bureaucratic costs
its administrative costs go down that's
the other thing that's in the background
here
it all raises the question that I want
to press you on a little bit which is
what are the limits of this argument uh
there's one question from a commenter
that kind of gets to this point uh
faximoa zigortu says wrong it's
certainly the government's purview to
look after public health and combat
misinformation nobody's Free Speech was
violated
are there circumstances in which the
government and a private company
private social media company can
communicate I mean there are issues of
people doing planning criminal activity
for instance where you might want to
have some conversations with the FBI a
back Channel type thing are those sort
of things allowed under your theory and
how do you draw those bounds they're not
only allowed under my theory they're
allowed under the injunction judges just
have to win the issue an injunction they
just have to tell you what you can't do
don't do this don't do that but here the
judge went out of his way to say all the
things the government was worried that
it wouldn't be able to do and you can do
this if you want to tell them that
there's a possible violation of law go
tell them that if you want to tell them
that there's been child trafficking go
that there's terrorist activity go tell
them that whenever you have an actual
violation of law you can go talk to them
but if if nobody's Free Speech rights
were violated your free speech rights
are violated when the government stops
your message from getting out and it's
clear that happened to Alex Berenson
it's clear it happened to RFK it's clear
it happened to Jay bhattacharya and
anybody associated with the Great
Barrington because they may not have
used his name but they said we want to
take down the Great Barrington
declaration and everything associated
with it that wasn't done by these
companies so their first amendment
rights were taken away by the government
because absent the government you take
away the hand of the government and it
wouldn't have happened that's what all
the facts show
Jay what is your reaction to you know
because in a in a way you are kind of
like one of the easier people to defend
because a lot of what you said turned
out to be right I mean you're wrong
every now and then but uh there's also a
lot of people who are just insane uh
that gather huge following yeah and they
they gather just you know giant
followings spewing stuff that doesn't
add up and and possibly leads people
down harmful paths what is this
experience
um like how's that made you think about
dealing with that issue of like the real
charlatans and um you know frauds out
there
I mean I I believe I I remember reading
John Stuart Mill in college and I think
he on free speech and I think he's right
the only answer to this is is more
speech
um I think what happened uh is that uh
you you have a deficit of trust in
authorities when they deserve a lack of
trust it's an earned lack of trust if
you want to counter people that are are
that are putting out you know ridiculous
claims about some supplement or
something well you have a given
Authority like in the FDA saying look
there's no evidence behind this and uh
and you you know if you're if you're if
people trust the authority then the
spread of that idea will will naturally
decline not because you said you can't
spread the idea but but because the idea
doesn't have Merit
um if you want if you want as a
government to have uh uh to to improve
the health of the population you don't
do it by saying this person is a bad guy
let's not let his speech go out there
what you do is by saying look this
person's what's this is what what
scientific evidence is saying about what
this person is saying and put it on the
put it on the web you know as they I
mean they have a bully poll but the
government it's not like the government
can't get its message out John's
mentioned this multiple times he's
absolutely right you put something on
the CDC website and now all of a sudden
not just it's not just that the the
public pays attention to it courts pay
attention to it like I've I've been
involved with cases throughout the
pandemic where the cdc's public
pronouncements were taking it taken as
as if it were gospel right by the courts
um so I I think the the government's
power to spread ideas is is pretty
substantial uh what what it did during
the pandemic was go far beyond that to
try to suppress criticism of its ideas
even when it was wrong because it
couldn't it had to compensate for the
lack of trust that the people had in in
the government and it was an earned lack
of trust because the government was
wrong Time After Time After Time on
basic facts during the pandemic that
harmed the lives of Regular People
schools closed forever even though there
was a very strong scientific evidence
that it wasn't going to do anything you
just have to look at Sweden
um and yet like the the scientists the
the government scientists swore up and
down that was necessary to keep the
close schools schools closed or they
we've been banging the drama masking
tonsils I could I can go on and on about
the scientific information the
government spread it's that lack of
trust that really needed to get
addressed and censorship is not the way
to address it
I want to press on one more point of
possible disagreement with John before I
ask one last question of both of you
which is one thing that has given me
some pause about your lawsuit is the way
that you view section 230 that we
touched on earlier and the way you view
social media companies is a little bit
at odds with how I view it and I think a
lot of people have reason view it
um you write here that in your complaint
that social media platforms are akin to
Common carriers or and or public
accommodations that under long-standing
statutory and common law doctrines
should be subject to non-discrimination
rules in accessing their platforms in a
in a way to summarize what I think
you're saying there it's that because uh
they are just kind of carrying
information like a phone line would that
means they should not be able to
suppress boosts or otherwise uh you know
make it more difficult for certain types
of content to to be accessed uh is is
that a correct summation of the
viewpoint
so the ncla doesn't have a position on
Section 230 in this common carrier fight
that I know is brewing
I think that that is more that what we
do believe is that these social media uh
it is sort of a Public Square and that
regardless of what the social media
companies because what you have there is
the social media companies have their
own First Amendment rights a little
different from the government
so so this this first amendment overlap
makes it I'm not good Old Pine on that
because we don't really take a position
but what we do say is that uh to the EXT
that whatever's on there can't be
influenced by the government because
either it's a Public Square and they're
not allowed to have message
um discrimination in the Public Square
or they're private companies that they
can't force or Cal Joel into changing
what should be on that on that platform
so it's either one or the other they
lose either way yeah okay so yeah you're
setting up this dichotomy of like if it
is true that they're they are allowed to
have this symbiotic relationship with
government then they need to be
functioning like a Public Square
otherwise the government needs to step
out and not be so involved and then you
can let it unfold in the market as it
sort of is now I mean you've got Elon
Musk taking over Twitter having his own
set of norms saying we're going to let a
lot of information that was not allowed
to Run Free Run free on Twitter now Mark
Zuckerberg then steps in and starts a
competitor called threads where like
we're going to be a little bit uh
tougher on our moderation and you can
kind of choose between the two to me
that's like the ideal way for that to
play out but to your point uh it's hard
to play out that way if there's all this
stuff happening behind the scenes and as
a legal matter you don't know which way
the Court's going to do so go so you set
it up so that you win either way that's
what that's
I like that okay so uh my final question
for both of you I'll go to you uh first
uh John
what is uh let's say that you get the
ruling that you want here
how does that change the world for the
better how does that change the way that
social media operates like how would
things look different uh going forward
post a decision in your favor let's say
even a Supreme Court decision let's
let's dream big uh how would things look
different uh henceforth so here's how
it's going to look different the media
comp the social media companies
themselves will know that this
injunction is in place and they they
won't be afraid of the government
anymore that it can't be yelling at them
every all the long day and they'll have
they'll have the protection of this of
this injunction and know what the law is
particularly if it comes from the
Supreme Court right so I think that when
you're taking off social media after
this you'll be more confident that isn't
because someone in the government has
been wanting to take your message away
now there might be a YouTube or someone
else who wants to take your message away
but that's a different suit a different
problem as you point out
um for another day and I and there's one
last thing I think that this this I
think it's come out of the colleges when
I was a kid everyone said sticks and
stones will break my bones but names
will never hurt me this idea of that
there's really dangerous harmful speech
that the speech comes out and everyone's
hurt and it's not even named they
haven't even said anything about you
it's just something you don't want to
hear well that is a new thing in my
experience I mean that's like the last
10 20 years and I don't want to hear my
government uh government people saying
this is harmful speech well harmful
speech gets hit right Alex Jones he got
a big judgment against him right they
showed harm they showed him speech he
was on the internet that that's how you
take care of it you don't take care of
it by saying it's harmful speech take it
down and it's harmful because I don't
like it
and my question for you Jay is you know
you've laid out a vision of it's It's
the classical liberal ideal of we have a
kind of an adult ongoing sometimes messy
public conversation even under real
maybe even especially under very
difficult trying circumstances like a
health emergency
how optimistic are you that that is
where we're headed are do you think that
there's been learning over these past
years are you pessimistic do you think
that it's actually going in the other
direction or some mixture of the two
um I mean I I think
I I don't know if you ask me one day
I'll change my mind on this from like
from the other I I at times I'm very
very optimistic and I don't see how in
the long run we don't have that as the
main the enlightenment uh ideal is that
right it's like science doesn't function
outside of an environment of free speech
and we have hundreds of years of history
of that being a productive way to to and
engage in science I think a lot of
people of Goodwill see that
but on other days I see the people that
that suppress speech that got so much on
covet wrong employing essentially raw
power to try to uh to try to to I mean
you know to to to like keep this regime
of suppression and control in place
um and it depresses me so I don't know I
think there's we're at a Crossroads and
we as Society have to decide uh and I at
one point in time I thought it would
just be you know reason you know we
could talk to each other and figure out
how to what what which which direction
will go and I was pretty confident that
we would win
um you know like it just takes good
science to replace bad science now I
don't know I mean I'm much more of the
minded it's going to take some political
movement to try to re-establish free
speech um which depresses me because
I've always had this feeling that this
idea that it would be science that would
that would be that would that would win
the day rather than brought political
power I'm seeing now raw political power
uh I mean I got involved in this case
I've just said I've never really been in
a plaintiff in a case before I I just
it's it's been real it's been a it's
been an eye-opening experience but I I
fortunately don't see any other way
other than to have this as a political
fight uh in in the in the political
arena in order to win and I don't know
which direction it's going to go
zooming in on the science point just for
a second what
um
what is the state of
kind of academic science I guess
particularly in public health at this
point you know I imagine now things have
gotten more contentious than ever
um how how has the field changed uh
postcovid
it feels like it's corrupted Zach right
so you you have um you have essentially
a small group of very powerful
scientific funders who uh controlled the
the the the the speech of scientists
during the pan I forget for not never
mind through this the kinds of
mechanisms we talked about through
social media but by essentially threats
right they'd say that when they when
Francis Collins wrote that I'm a fringe
epidemiologist and call for a
devastating takedown he's the he's the
main head of the NIH National Institute
of Health 45 billion dollars of funding
that determines these the Career Success
of basically every biomedical scientist
of known in this country you go on the
outs with the NIH and your your
Scientific careers it's a threat a lot
of people a lot of scientists stayed
silent because of that that threat
um and a lot of people who got things
very very deeply wrong during the
pandemic in science
um they're they're essentially they
don't want people to to to to notice
that I mean since the cause for amnesty
and so on I don't see any way forward
for science outside of an honest
assessment of what happened I've called
for a a essentially a bipartisan honest
covet commission uh after what's what we
do after you know after like a plane
crash right you do it on an honest
evaluation of what happened the goal
isn't to destroy careers of people uh
the goal is to do an honest desk and say
here's what we got wrong here's what
we've got right and here's how we can
reform I think science desperately needs
something like that regarding the covet
pandemic uh I I I've been surprised in
the last year and some that that that
call for such a commission hasn't really
taken root in the United States uh and I
hope that that eventually that we'll be
able to do that but until something like
that happens I am I'm somewhat
pessimistic about uh the future of
science I mean has there been any
discussion among scientists about that
problem that you zeroed in on there
which is the concentration of I think
you said 45 billion dollars in the hands
of the NIH I mean what when you look
back on you know Eisenhower had his
famous military-industrial complex
speech if you go and watch that full
speech the second part of that speech is
he's also warning about what he calls
the scientific industrial complex which
is kind of concentrating all the
resources in this you know academic
governments like blob and that kind of
seems like that has also come true
is there any discussions if if politics
are the answer has there been any
effort to somehow decentralize the
scientific funding um to to alleviate
that problem because that that seems
like a more long-term solution rather
than hoping you get the right person in
an NIH or something
uh so I'm seeing some conversation
around that on both the Democratic and
and Republican side but unfortunately
it's not by the central uh most
important but it's not it's not Biden
and Trump that I'm seeing that from uh I
mean I've seen that from RFK Jr I've
seen that from DeSantis
um uh whether they can win the day on
that is unclear to me uh I I don't again
I don't think it's a purely partisan
issue I think it is a question of of
concentration of power and who benefits
from that concentration of power uh I'm
I'm I mean I'm in the uh I'm gonna try
to like start advocating around that
because I think it's fundamentally
important for the future of science that
we have this sort of decentralization of
power I don't see how any way of getting
the government out of funding those
kinds of I mean I think uh that it
solves a real problem like there's a lot
of science that can't be done by private
in the private sector because there's
you know a lot of science is is public
knowledge you can't really patent it um
so but so the question is how do you uh
use the power the government has so that
you get the most out of the taxpayer
dollars I I think the way you do that is
by decentralized saying reducing the uh
you never ever put so much power over
the minds and speech the scientists in
the hands of one single or small very
small set of people and that goes not
just true for biomedical science for all
of Sciences I think a lot of what we're
seeing the discontent in science is that
that concentrated power has essentially
given uh scientists this message that if
you don't if you don't comply your
research career is going to go nowhere
um and that is if that's the end of the
Enlightenment uh and I think uh whether
we can reform that it's an open question
but that is really I think the
fundamental fight for the next uh for
the next decades for science
I think that's a good theme to end on
because you know trying to decentralize
that power and sort of break that uh
connection between the uh uh you know a
very small group of people in the
government and whether it's you know
science or social media
um that is that does seem to be like the
task of the next decade or so so I
appreciate both of you coming to join me
and and talk through this case it was uh
really Illuminating uh thanks to
everyone who tuned in as always we will
be back here Thursday 1 p.m Eastern I
hope you tune in and we'll see you next
week